a pesar de que varios sectores
permanecieron prácticamente paralizados
durante varios meses a causa de la
pandemia fue justamente en medio de la
emergencia que surgieron algunas
iniciativas solidarias para intentar
brindar apoyo a los más necesitados
soy el mar y ángulo y en esta edición
especial de la serie de france 24 les
mostraré varias de ellas
empezamos en latinoamérica porque en
mexico un comedor de beneficiencia vio
llegar público nuevo a los habitantes de
calle que siempre ayudaban se sumaron
desempleados y madres cabeza de hogar a
las que la emergencia las dejó sin la
posibilidad de ganarse el sustento
adentro de lunes a viernes en este
comedor vicentino misioneros y
voluntarios preparan raciones de comida
para la gente necesitada pedimos al
señor que le agrega estos alimentos pero
la crisis que trajo el cubit ha hecho
estos religiosos redoblar esfuerzos y
afuera decenas de personas hacen filas
desde el mediodía en espera de recibir
los alimentos que manda el gobierno de
la ciudad a este comedor javier coordina
la recepción de los platillos y es él
quien hace la entrega en las 280
raciones aumentó a 400 raciones y ha
querido en 13 empleados sobre todo viene
mucho más más soltera
en el chico más de un millón de personas
han perdido su empleo durante la
pandemia ya este comedor en el centro de
la ciudad ya no llega alguien en esa
situación
eladio es veterinario y también para le
obras pero el congelamiento afectó su
centro de trabajo por ello viene aquí
porque manda mi fuente de ingresos más
llevar el ala del archivo del
asentamiento por la pandemia no cerraron
ahora estoy esperando para poder iniciar
de nuevo cuenta mi vida actividad
como investigador a nueve kilómetros al
cliente la historia y se repite con un
restaurante de antojitos mexicanos como
el comedor vicentino a este restaurante
comenzó a llegar no sólo gente en
situación de calle sino también víctimas
del desempleo
diego adrián de 20 años perdió su
trabajo cuando se confinó el poder
judicial llamaba a las huelgas
de limpieza limpia
[Música]
aquí también aumentaron las raciones que
regalan diariamente y procuran que nunca
se vaya a alguien sin recibir algo de
comida al segundo trimestre del año el
porcentaje de personas en pobreza
laboral fue de 48.1 por ciento aunque
instituciones como el consejo nacional
de evaluación de políticas de desarrollo
estiman que la pandemia aumentará hasta
en 10 millones más las personas en
pobreza por ingresos vamos a francia
donde la precariedad en la que viven
muchas personas entre ellas migrantes
indocumentados que perdieron sus
trabajos por los efectos del coronavirus
quedó al descubierto con el
confinamiento para auxiliarlo surgieron
varias asociaciones en parís un grupo de
colombianos le apostó a apoyar a sus
compatriotas ante la crisis
erika olavarría los acompaño en una de
sus jornadas
jamie catalina es un estudiante
colombiana que se gana la vida como
camarera lleva dos años en francia la
acompaña a su pareja colombiano también
pero indocumentado trabajaba en el
sector de la construcción pero desde el
inicio de la cuarentena no tiene trabajo
el coi 19 a golpeado con fuerza la
economía de su hogar y por eso reciben
ayuda alimentaria estamos justos además
que toca pagar alquiler
también me toca pagar la universidad
la señora es muy paciente pero igual hay
que pagar que más hermano bien no no
hablar con cuanta débil de lo de la baja
la bacanería esta ayuda alimentaria es
una iniciativa de un grupo de
colombianos en francia que decidió
organizarse para ir en auxilio de sus
compatriotas en dificultad este primero
de mayo los que reparten son máximo
quite ver y juan david castillo conocido
como el man de los chorizos en tiempos
normales vendes salchichas y de paso
descubre historias que difunde en sus
redes sociales
bueno eso es una invitación que recibí
de una pareja de ingenieros colombianos
que tenían la idea de ayudar y me
llamaron a mí como para que les ayudara
con la discusión que yo les propuse que
en vez de ayudarles con la discusión
también me metía pues como ayudar en la
campaña porque ya ya ya recibió pues
bastante solicitudes pues como de ayuda
entonces ya se estaba sintiendo la
necesidad ya especialmente cuando
estamos en una situación normal están
pintando casas pintando restaurantes
cambiando haciendo comida hacen parte
pues de la de la sociedad pero en este
momento es pero no están excluidos la
asociación que nació apenas en abril
está ayudando ya a más de 800 personas
pues se entrega también bonos de mercado
y ha instalado un sistema de
apadrinamiento de familias por otras
familias para el que están poniendo en
marcha una aplicación de internet
y ante el aumento de los niveles de
pobreza y desigualdad a raíz de la
pandemia en venezuela los nacionales de
ese país que viven en italia se unieron
para poner en marcha un programa de
donación de medicinas una apuesta
ciudadana para intentar atajar la
escasez de fármacos en los hospitales
del gigante petrolero exacerbada por la
pandemia
esta mañana daniela y su esposo
recorrieron decenas de kilómetros con un
objetivo participar en una iniciativa de
solidaridad hacia el continente
latinoamericano hoy traen medicamentos
para dar en donación estuvimos de luto
en la familia y quedamos con todas estas
medicinas que sobraban pero en todo caso
todavía están buenas y algunas son
costosas entonces dijimos que las
podíamos donar a esta asociación por
venezuela sin perder ni un segundo la
donación entró en un circuito bien
preciso
[Aplausos]
una armada de voluntarios examina y
cataloga cada fármaco aquí convergen
medicinas que llegan de toda italia
donadas por privados o por instituciones
de poco producto eduardo bruni es el
fundador de este proyecto médico
cirujano nacido en venezuela desde hace
cinco años organiza estas colectas una
iniciativa que ha adquirido una
importancia particular desde la
explosión de la pandemia en este país
latinoamericano esto es un antibiótico
que utilísimo en este momento de la
situación kobe de venezuela para los
enfermos que tienen primero monya y
sobre infección master y acá en
venezuela no hay antibióticos no se
consiguen y los que se consiguen son de
un precio demasiado exagerados desde el
inicio de la pandemia más de siete mil
kilos de medicinas han sido enviados
gracias a la ayuda de patrocinadores que
financian el envío en el marco de una
campaña internacional de ayuda a
venezuela nosotros hemos canalizado con
la ayuda humanitaria venezuela de europa
vienen los medicamentos
eeuu gracias a la alianza que tenemos
con el programa ayuda humanitaria para
venezuela ellos envían lo que es todo el
presidio sanitario o sea los insumos
médicos la mayoría de los voluntarios
aquí presentes son de origen venezolano
las cajas listas son selladas y
preparadas para el transporte en pocos
días atravesarán el océano atlántico a
borde de un barco de carga con destino
al puerto de la guaira al norte de
caracas en venezuela
pero en una planta móvil de distribución
gratuita de oxígeno se convirtió en la
única esperanza para seguir respirando
para decenas de ciudadanos que por la
escasez y los elevados precios no
lograban acceder a los suministros esta
iniciativa surgió luego de la tragedia
familiar que vivió un joven alcalde al
perder a su padre a causa del virus
a sus 49 años josé gonzález vive el
momento más crítico de su vida
desde hace tres semanas tiene el joven
19 como los hospitales están saturados
su familia trata de atenderlo en casa no
tienen dinero para comprar medicinas ni
oxígeno
por eso su cuñada sale a buscar el gas
medicinal que gratuitamente ha llegado a
su vecindario necesita requiere el
oxígeno no puede estar sin el oxígeno le
falta el aire su corazón ya se le siente
que se lo está pagando su corazón sin el
oxígeno él no puede no puede estar
pacientes como jose gonzalez reciben
oxígeno gracias a esta planta móvil que
recorre los distritos más pobres de lima
basta acreditar a un pariente contagiado
para recargar gratuitamente los balones
con el gas medicinal la muerte de su
padre a causa del mortal patógeno
inspiró este joven alcalde a emprender
la ayuda social que dos semanas también
viajará al interior del país el perú
sufre ya y adolece de un déficit
tremendo en cuanto al oxígeno no razón
por la cual nosotros los gobierno
locales no no se nos hemos tenido que
unir para trabajar estrategias distintas
a las que viene trabajando el gobierno
pero pero son estrategias que esperemos
que sean replicadas por el gobierno
nacional julia pérez ya recargo el
oxígeno para su cuñado mañana tendrá que
madrugar y repetir el mismo
para que su familiar puede seguir
viviendo terminamos en brasil donde el
aislamiento preventivo se convirtió para
muchos ancianos en una suerte de condena
a la soledad pero para menguar la
melancolía de algunos surgió una
iniciativa que bajo el nombre de
historias por teléfono logró reunir a
cerca de 1500 voluntarios para que le
apostarán a alegrar los días de los
adultos mayores
leyendo lees cuentos y poemas
yo quería leerle un poema puedo el poema
se llaman reinicio sigue la dura vida la
vida dura
sin ninguna obstrucción de mi querer
todos los días
eduardo de clava un soneto a un anciano
que enfrenta solo en su casa la dura
rutina del confinamiento les voy a
mandar a matar este poema habla de
recomenzar en este momento que estamos
aislados es muy importante pensar en
recomenzar pensando comienza eduardo es
uno de los 1500 voluntarios del proyecto
historias por teléfono desde que empezó
la pandemia este escritor ha atendido a
más de 60 mayores primero sobre leer un
poema de su autoría y después conversa
un rato con sus oyentes
voy a recibir respuestas de señoras y
señores a los que ya me respuestas
incluso muy emocionantes
hola eduardo muy bonito muchas gracias
gracias por sus llamadas
gracias por su poema
a veces los usuarios de este servicio le
piden que les envíe su soneto sus versos
vuelan por calles y barrios y llegan a
todos los rincones del río de janeiro
como la favela de la mar efe - amenizar
los dolores yo con toda seguridad
recomendaría este proyecto a otras
personas porque hay personas que viven
solas no tienen a nadie viven en la
soledad recibir una llamada para oír una
historia o un poema es una buena manera
de ayudar a una persona whatsapp hasta
ahora más de 5000 ancianos se han
beneficiado de esta iniciativa que el
poeta brasileño carlos drummond de
andrade
sin dudas vería con buenos ojos que
puede un humano sino entre humanos amar
la idea es que el proyecto siga después
del fin de la pandemia y que se
promuevan encuentros presenciales entre
lectores y oyentes
sin duda estas iniciativas nos muestran
como sin importar fronteras o
nacionalidades la pandemia también logró
movilizar grupos para apoyar a los más
vulnerables en estos tiempos de crisis
gracias por acompañarnos sigan con más
aquí en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]